l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est la
démission d'alain grise et le ministre
en charge des pme pour à la suite de sa
condamnation pour non déclaration aux
déclarations incomplètes de patrimoine
qu'est l'enseignement vous tirer de
cette affaire il n'y a pas
d'enseignement en particulier la du
justice a été rendue et alain grise et
je crois d'ailleurs dans un communiqué
indiquant qu'il ne voulait vous êtes
l'action du gouvernement puisse au coin
semaine et dans des conditions sereines
a décidé de présenter sa démission j'ai
pas commenter les décisions de justice
j'ai pas à commenter les conséquences
que prennent les collègues ou des élus
qui prennent ces décisions là je vois
juste salué l'action de la grise et
comme ministre des pme artisanat du
commerce il a beaucoup agi après une
décision de justice elle s'impose à nous
tous si et quand la décision qui permet
aussi de retrouver une forme de sérénité
qui va être remplacé ben vous verrez ce
que dira le premier ministre ou ce que
proposera le premier ministre au
président de la république vous avez pas
d'information là-dessus je n'ai su ce
quand bien même j'en aurais quand bien
même j'en ai je n'ai pas à vous en
donner
[Musique]